with most of the country already under
extreme measures
it's clear that we need to do more
together to bring this new variant under
control
while our vaccines are rolled out
in england we must therefore go into a
national lockdown
which is tough enough to contain this
variant
that means the government is once again
instructing you to stay at home
you may only leave home for limited
reasons permitted in law
such as to shop for essentials to work
if you
absolutely cannot work from home to
exercise
to seek medical assistance such as
getting a copied test
or to escape domestic abuse
the full details of what you can and
can't do will be available
at gov dot uk forward slash coronavirus
if you're a clinically extremely
vulnerable we're advising you to begin
shielding again and you will shortly
receive a letter
about what this means for you
and because we now have to do everything
we possibly can to stop
the spread of the disease primary
schools
secondary schools and colleges across
england
must move to remote permit provision
from tomorrow
except for vulnerable children and the
children
of key workers everyone will still be
able to access earlier settings
such as nurseries we recognize
that this will mean it's not possible or
fair
for all exams to go ahead this summer as
normal
the education secretary will work with
off quo to put in place
alternative arrangements we will provide
extra support to ensure that pupils
entitled to free school meals
we'll continue to receive them while
schools are closed
and we will distribute more devices to
support
remote education